tu ne peux pas être ici
tu sais que je ne peux pas être le premier à
vouloir voir mon plus jeune moi
étrange
te regarder naître
notre dynastie génétique a régné pendant
près de quatre siècles
la puissance de l'imperium
a apporté la paix à des milliers de mondes
mais les croyances d'un homme
menacent maintenant l'existence même de l'empire
je ne suis pas un révolutionnaire
ses calculs sont corrects
l'empire est en train de mourir l'
ordre disparaîtra les
guerres seront sans fin
ne peuvent que raccourcir l'obscurité
l'homme a un maître qui suit les
gens qui fondent leurs espoirs sur  tous les
mots tenus dans d'autres
mots ont une façon d'attiser les
incendies de forêt
vous ne pouvez pas vous sauver
mais vous pouvez sauver votre héritage
vous